So far everything I've talked about really applies to every programming
language. In fact, it applies to lots of things beyond programming. Whether
you're designing a house, designing a company, planning and event. All of those
things benefit from doing things in a modular way and thinking about how to
break the problem down into small pieces with clean interfaces. Now we're going
to talk about some of the specifics of how to actually do this in python. And in
Python we can divide a program into modules which are really just separate
files. In order for one file to use another file, once we have divided our
program into separate files, in order to use what's in one file in the other
file, we need to import. We can thus using the syntax import followed by the
module name. So if we're in the file a dot py and we want to use something from
b dot py. We will just do import b. Python will look for a file named b.py.
That's the simplest case, and it will find it in the current directory. If it
doesn't find that file there, there are other ways it will look for a module.
And it will look on a path of directories to find it, but the ones that create
yourself will probably be in the same directory as the file that you're working
on. Until your programs get really complicated and then you'll organize those
into directories as well. We've used import before and you've seen the import
"urllib" in some of the code that, that used in search engine. This was used to
be able to use a function to get a page from the web. We didn't define this
ourselves and if you look in the directory there's no "urllib" dot py file. This
is a module provided by the Python library. Since we didn't define this
ourselves, Python will search for this on the path until it finds it. We can see
what that path is by doing import sys to import the sys module, and then looking
at the value of path defined in the sys module, and we see this long path. Your
results will very depending on how you installed Python and what platform you're
working on. The specifics that you see here will depend on your Python
installation. You should see the first entry is the current path. There's an
empty directory here, meaning it's always going to look in the current directory
first, but then it's going to look in a bunch of different library directories
to try to find the packet you're looking for. The other thing want to point out
here. Is the syntax I used here. This is the way that obtain a definition from a
module. So, we imported this module to act as the definition from that module,
we need to sue the module followed by a dot. And then, we can access the
definitions in that module. What this means is that modules avoid name space
pollution. If we didn't have to use the module to reference definitions in the
imported files. Well then everytime we imported a file, we'd have to worry
about, does it use any names that we use, and are we going to lose our own
definitions and have pollution that way? The way Python avoids that is by, when
you import a module, all the names to find in that file are only visible inside
the module, followed by the module, dot the name. This means that if you had
your own path variable and then you import sys, the value of path hasn't
changed.